you know you said something funny to me
yesterday robin you made an observation
we were back in the office and i'm
sitting back there and i'm having an
argument with gary because i got very
frustrated
i'm going on vacation next week and gary
had to arrange some office stuff
you know people to answer the phones
whatever what have you
and finally i turned to gary and i just
said gary
the reason i hired you is so that you
could take care of trivial crap like
this don't bring it to me
he goes well both i have to bring it to
you because
tom won't listen to me no i didn't say
tom wouldn't listen to me
i said that come on listen to me on this
when it comes to matters of money
right and me trying to get more money
out of the office
i don't your quote was tom doesn't take
me seriously
on these issues so gary leaves the room
and robin says to me
well of course tom doesn't take gary
seriously in any way look at how he
dresses like a cub scout
i said you're right i said look at him i
said the guy wants to be taken seriously
as a producer
he wears these shorts that look like
beavers and butthead
you know everyone everyone around here
like seriously the way you and then i
looked at you and i was like oh my god
you look
you look like we said you look like you
were going on a camping trip yeah
how could anyone take you seriously
about anything when you dress like that
i don't think that has anything to do
with it i think i proved it
look at look at the shorts you can look
at the big hairy legs with the hairy
legs hanging out of your pants
i mean you don't even look like a and
you're wearing like one of those
t-shirts that
the the audience sends in in all
seriousness i swear i'm not just saying
this for a radio
you look like to me i don't you look
like a kid on who's going out on a cub
scout camping trip you're talking about
that t-shirt today i remember when he
used to wear a marv in the martian
t-shirt
every other day and he's going in
conducting business in that t-shirt and
the shorts
he walks into tom's office in the shorts
you can't possibly be taken seriously
the way you dress right
so what was the other excuse for the
other nine and a half years
when i wasn't wearing shorts what is the
excuse
in other words was i taken more
seriously last year i don't know where
your pants were
but gary you've been dressing like this
since you got here you have never really
changed your dress that much
the long pants come out for the winter
that's true and there are only jeans
and farmer jones jeans i'm just saying
man
i think you'd be taking a lot more
seriously if you dressed a little more
like the people in management here i
don't say wear a suit and tie i want to
work on that yeah seriously
you know we get an important guest in
and publicist and the publicists all
come dressed for success you know they
have a certain work attire
gary greets them wearing a porky pig
tank
oh hello over my porky pig tank top
welcome to the show hello i'm working on
the show i'm the producer
never kept us from getting gas okay i
can't see you on the phone
yeah a lot of the publicists really
respond to you they do gary he's living
up to his name boy gary
yeah he's like a boy he looks like a
little boy the puppet dress is better
you know you dress better gary puppet
than me
thank you both i have yosemite same
underwear on today all right but at
least it's in your underwear
is there no one else on the show to make
fun of i mean you know this i i mean
yesterday you really look goofy i gotta
tell you well i'm wearing the same thing
i'm wearing
i'm just be equally i'm desensitized
because you know i'm i don't think about
that stuff but
robin made a good point but you do get
desensitized to it after but you do
think of gary as a kid
when you see him dress like a little kid
maybe it's a bad cycle because since you
guys treat me like i'm so unimportant
maybe that's how i dress
maybe that's it you know what's the bad
side all right right
it's always someone else's fault just
dress better because the way you dress
now you might as well wear an arrow
through your head
[Music]
and you want a compliment seriously no
no i'm going to give it to you you have
perfect teeth how's that
all right it didn't cost you a time
what is it gary as long as we're doing a
makeover could we make over my head
because i don't look like that slob no
more
we didn't get a makeover on youtube
thank you wolf all right very good gary
i'm glad we have this little
conversation
shorts tomorrow we're back on september
7th new gary oh no
no you can't change tomorrow i don't
have anything to change into i don't
believe that
i've seen you dressed i have anything
comfortable to change into
think about it if it really disturbs you
don't do it but you know i just think it
would help the show
well there's nobody there's no publicist
to me tomorrow give me one more day
i wonder what you have i want to do it
right put a pair of jeans if you still
fit in your jeans i fit in a painting
and a shirt okay we'll be back right
after these words